A Canadian couple was so fed up with LGBTQ people
and wokeness that they sold everything they owned
and moved to Russia.
And boy was it a disaster.
You may have heard about Aaron and an ISA Feinstro,
conservative Christian farmers from Canada
who likely with the help of lots of propaganda,
are so afraid of LGBTQ people
and so convinced that Russia has a Utopia
they moved eight of their nine children there.
Eldest is rumored to have stayed back in Canada
because he thinks his parents are.
How can I put this politely? Not.
And at first glance
Russia seems like a perfect place for them to go.
The country has been actively recruiting people
like the fiendsteris
and even announced plans to build a migrant
village near Moscow for disgruntled right wingers
sick and tired of queer people having rights
or whatever.
The feesters answered that call,
sold their farm
in their whole real estate business
and moved to Russia
with the assurance that
the government would help them find farmland.
But seems like the Russians were
lol jk about that
cause that's not really how it went.
Shortly after they arrived,
all of their assets were frozen,
officials who promised to help them disappeared,
and since they don't speak Russian,
they couldn't even get information,
let alone their money.
The whole debacle had Mrs.
Feinster saying that she was ready to jump on a plane
and get out of here,
but it seems
in the intervening Weeks?
The feinsters have worked something
out with the Russians.
Since posting a groveling apology to Russia for Mrs.
Feinster basically being like
I hate it here.
They've basically pivoted their YouTube channel to
propaganda. I'm sorry,
I meant to say
glowing tales of their new life in Russia.
It's all chicken farms
and squashing the western media and what not.
So hooray for happy endings,
I guess. Still,
imagine being so upset about a group of people
who have no impact on your life whatsoever.
Also don't even make up 10% of the population
that you go through
all of this just to get away from them.
The grass is always greener,
as the saying goes.
And propaganda works.